[Music]
hi
mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an american science fiction
action film called elysium
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the premise of the movie is set in the
year 2154
when the earth is overpopulated and
polluted beyond rehabilitation many new
diseases have evolved making half of the
population sick what once used to be
beautiful cities have turned into slums
society has divided into the higher and
lower classes and the financial gap
between the two is exponential the
wealthy and powerful people have created
their own new place to live far away
from the poor they live in a space
station that lies on the earth's orbit
called elysium elysium is a utopian city
with no sadness or sickness it has all
kinds of luxurious resources and among
them the most important is the facility
of med bay med bays are privately owned
medical chambers that can instantly heal
any disease known to humanity or any
form of physical injury while life on
elysium is magical life on the earth is
the exact opposite
people are governed by mindless robot
police who beat them in the name of the
zero tolerance policy at the beginning
of the movie a little boy named max
decosta and his friend frey santiago
read the stories about elysium and its
lavish life max promises frey that he
will take her to the elysium one day the
little boy lives in an orphanage that is
run by a nun whom he loves a lot his
ambition in life is to visit the elysium
one day
however many years later max has grown
up to be a criminal he and frey have
lost contact while his mother like none
is no more max is trying to recover from
his criminal past and is doing a normal
job at armadine corporation a factory
where weaponry for elysium and robot
police are manufactured
one day while going to work some robot
police approach max and break his wrist
for being disobedient he goes to the
hospital and is surprised to see his old
friend frey who has grown up to be a
nurse the two catch up while frey treats
max's injuries max tries to ask her out
but she leaves to tend to another
patient before he can the only thing
worse than living in the slums is living
in the friend zone
we see that the hospital is packed with
people which is considered normal
because of the overpopulation and
disease max then goes to work where half
of his pay is deducted for being late
the ceo of the armadine corporation is a
resident of elysium named john carlisle
he stays on earth to look after the
factories and only cares for the
company's profit he has no sympathy for
his workers problems at all a criminal
named spider has formulated an illegal
immigration operating system for the
people on earth to enter elysium but the
process is very risky as only some who
depart make it to elysium without harm
first they acquire the elysium
identification brands on their wrist
which allows them to access any facility
on elysium after that the people board
three rustic looking spaceships and head
for the space station as the ships get
closer the defense secretary of elysium
jessica delacorte is alerted about the
breach she contacts cm kruger a rogue
sleeper agent and her right-hand man on
earth krueger immediately obeys
jessica's orders and fires an air
missile launcher at the ships two of
them get shot but the missile misses the
third in the two ships that are
destroyed 46 people are killed
fortunately the last ship lands on
elysium however before the people aboard
the ship can run away jessica orders the
guards to apprehend everyone on board
the police choppers and robots chase the
earthers and arrest them the only two
people able to make it to a med bay are
a mother and her sick daughter the
daughter is healed in the med bay
because of her identification band when
she gets out of the machine the mother
is delighted to see that she can walk
properly right then the robot police
arrest the two the earthers who resist
are killed while the others are deported
back to the earth
back on earth max is at work when a door
at his workstation jams his supervisor
commands him to go inside and fix it
even though it is extremely dangerous
max obliges but as he goes inside the
door shuts and he is blasted with a wave
of lethal radiation oh boy well maybe
he'll get superpowers
a while later he is dragged from the bed
chamber and sent to a medical unit he is
then told by another robot that he will
soon experience catastrophic organ
failure and has only five days to live
the ceo john comes to see max lying on a
bed but cares more about the betting
being ruined than max's health a robot
gives max some pills to help him with
the pain and will keep him physically
functional until he dies
right after the last mission jessica is
summoned by patel the president of
elysium he isn't fond of jessica's
methods and doesn't support the
irresponsible killing of people but
jessica collapsed back by saying that
she won't allow the homes of their
future children elysium to be raided by
the earthers patel however threatens
jessica to fire her if she causes more
casualties and orders her to stop using
krueger immediately back on the earth
kruger is told to return all his weapons
because his service isn't needed anymore
he is enraged and feels betrayed by
jessica meanwhile max's criminal friend
julio sees him limping back from work
and goes to help him after julio helps
him to take his medicine max asks him to
find spider he is now desperate to go to
elysium as soon as possible to use a med
bay to heal himself max and julio go to
meet spider and ask him to send max to
elysium in turn for a favor max did for
him three years ago spider instead
offers him a task to plug into the brain
of one of elysium's high ranking
officials in order to obtain passcodes
and other secret data spyder wants to
use the information to acquire money
from the official's bank account
if max can do that spider will make sure
max gets to elysium and gets his
treatment max has no other way to save
his own life so he accepts the offer it
turns out the high-ranking official that
max has to get the information from is
jon the man who cared more about bed
sheets than max's life however spider
knows that max cannot fulfill his
mission in his current physical
condition so he performs a procedure on
him to attach a third generation powered
exoskeleton to his body and connect a
neural chip to his brain
this looks like a painful way to get
superpowers i think i'd rather get
bitten by a spider
the exoskeleton gives max the strength
that is equal to a police robot
in the following scene we see ceo john
meet jessica who is fed up with the
president's ideologies she wants jon to
reboot and override elysium's computer
core and reinstate her as the new
president
john agrees to do the job and goes back
to earth to reboot the computer program
as per her demand he also programs a
denial system that would kill anyone
attempting to download data from his
brain he then boards a shuttle for a
flight to elysium but the shuttle is
shot by max and his team before it can
leave earth they find the ceo and are
about to extract the required
information from him but a droid
confronts them and a shootout ensues jon
is shot in the process they managed to
defeat the droid and get the required
information from john's brain jessica is
angered about jon's situation and she
immediately sends krueger to get the
people who attacked john kruger and his
men arrive at the location and start
firing at max and his team all of his
teammates including his best friend
julio are killed but max manages to flee
from the scene jessica is now stressed
knowing that someone has access to her
top secret mission to overthrow the
president she jams all the signals in
the area so that no other spaceships can
leave
meanwhile kruger also gets his hands on
the data that was extracted from john's
brain he realizes the data is actually
jessica's secret program and encourages
his men to retrieve more of it
presumably for his own benefit in the
meantime a heavily injured max goes to
ask for help from frey she brings him to
her house and dresses his wounds he
wakes up the following day to see a
little girl in front of him it turns out
that she is frey's daughter who is ill
from leukemia and has very little time
left to live frey asks max to take her
to elysium but max claims that he is
being pursued by very dangerous people
and if they are associated with him they
will be killed too
after he leaves kruger and his men
arrive looking for max they take frey
and her little daughter hostage when
they find out max was treated there the
previous night after a while max goes to
spider with the code he retrieved from
john's brain but is disappointed to find
that all airspaces have been jammed by
jessica this means that spider cannot
keep his end of the offer and max cannot
be sent to elysium spider goes through
the code in max's brain and is beyond
surprised to see that it is code to
reset and reboot the entirety of elysium
if they can manage to rewrite the codes
and make everyone a citizen of elysium
all humans could enjoy the medbay
facility leaving no more disease in the
world spider tries to convince max to
wait until they can override elysium's
system which might take five days but
with hours left to live max wants to
sell the data to jessica in turn for a
chance to use the med bay and save his
life max realizes that kruger needs him
alive so when he comes to get him max
simply turns himself in inside krueger's
ship he is surprised to see frey and her
daughter both abducted kruger tells
jessica about them finding the code and
jessica lifts the air space jam allowing
krueger's ship with frey her daughter
and max to come to elysium this also
gives spider and his men a chance to
pursue max they get into a spaceship
with the intention of finding max and
using the code for the benefit of
humanity back on kruger's ship he
misbehaves with frey which angers max as
max retaliates their little argument
turns big and a shootout occurs inside
the ship max throws a grenade at krueger
blowing half of his face off the ship's
control system is damaged and it crashes
onto a lavish house in elysium jessica
orders for everyone aboard the ship to
be brought to her frey brings her
daughter out of the destroyed ship and
goes inside the nearest house looking
for a med bay she finds one and tries to
use it on her daughter but it doesn't
work since she doesn't have citizenship
the guards eventually catch all of them
and take them to jessica krueger's men
put krueger in a med bay and fix his
face
meanwhile jessica puts max on a machine
to extract all the information from his
head but the extraction is sure to kill
him she asks her men to go ahead with it
because max's life is worth nothing to
her after jessica leaves krueger's men
take frey and her daughter back the
doctors are about to extract the
information from max's brain and kill
him but he manages to free himself just
in time at the same time jessica
belittles krueger for crashing his
spaceship and threatening the life of
elysium's citizens as she insults him an
enraged kruger stabs her in the neck he
plans to rewrite the code and make
himself the president of elysium
kruger's men set off to kill all the
politicians in the facility while he
goes to rewrite the code meanwhile
spider and his men also land on elysium
looking for max they are in the facility
tracking his location max on the other
hand is looking for frey when he sees
that spider is in the facility through a
screen he contacts him and tells him to
go forward with the plan of making
everyone elysium citizen and thus
eradicating all diseases from earth max
then rescues frey and meets spider at
the same time he sends frey to the
nearest med bay and asks her to wait
until they recode everyone as elysium
citizen so her daughter can be healed
after that max along with spider make
their way to recode the system but are
caught by kruger on the way max and
kruger get into an intense fight but max
is easily overpowered however the course
of the fight changes when max manages to
take off kruger's neural chip thus
dismantling his whole system after
defeating him max and spider get to the
mainframe and get ready to extract the
code from max's brain however since ceo
john had coded that anyone who extracts
the code will be killed the only way to
save everyone else in the world is for
max to die in his limited time max calls
frey and tells her that he had kept the
promise he made to her when they were
little he then looks at the earth and
compares it to a locket his
non-caretaker had given him way back
after the emotional moment he presses
the button to reboot elysium's system
and sacrifices himself in the process
the system then registers every human as
a citizen freya's daughter is healed in
the med bay meanwhile many ships are
sent to the earth with med bays to help
people recover from diseases and
injuries
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out
thank you for watching